vous savez dans cette affaire les choses
sont de plus en plus graves
nous qui sommes co rapporteurs je suis
co rapporteur avec muriel jourda de la
commission denquête nous travaillons
nous regardons tous nous avons procédé à
des 40 ou 50 heures d'audition nous
avons sollicité l'envoi de très nombreux
documents nous sommes avons beaucoup et
nous travaillons nous faisons notre
travail
et lorsque nous rendrons le rapport nous
vous dirons les conclusions que nous
proposerons au sénat que d'en tirer à
partir du moment où monsieur banal a été
considéré comme porteur d'une autorité
particulière
beaucoup de personnes ce sont les
indices fonctionné que ce soit l'elysée
unitaire de l'intérieur
la préfecture de police au quai d'orsay
dans les ambassades
peut-être à matignon donc toute une
série de choses se sont produites
autrement qu'elle soit douce produire
tout un tas de comportement pourrait on
était autre que ce qui aurait dû se
passer normalement ouvriers